[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler du film
l'homme bicentenaire un film réalisé par
chris columbus en 1999
chris columbus très connu pour harry
potter maman j'ai raté l'avion ou encore
madame doubtfire c'est très drôle que tu
dis ça parce que kassim nous avons robin
williams double guild sag des toits
disparu et sam neill jurassic park
ces deux acteurs là vont vous présenter
un film qui a parlé de la place de la
technologie au sein de la société au
sein de la famille on va voir également
véritable leçon de vie un robot qui va
avoir des sentiments des sensations et
donc on va voir la définition de l'amour
de la tristesse de la joie du bonheur un
de la compassion et à travers ces
définitions là on va voir un très fort
passage présentées par william sur
l'amour l'amour avec le grand a
avec un texte une écriture scénaristique
véritablement forte et digne de poésie
ce film aura fait un flop au box office
et pourtant derrière aura eu une
nomination aux oscars et aura eu un
engouement auprès du public et pour ça
je vous laisse le découvrir
[Musique]